[Musica]
quante volte avete sentito parlare di
honda tecnologica è quello di cui mi
occupo ma è curioso perché ogni volta
che sento questo termine
io non posso fare a meno di pensare alle
onde dell'oceano tra gli sport che
pratico
infatti il surf è decisamente il mio
preferito è anche se non è sempre quello
in cui ho i migliori risultati
se c'è una cosa che ho imparato è che
quando sei lì in mezzo all'oceano e sta
arrivando un onda di due o tre metri
puoi fare solo due cose evitarla
spostandoti dal suo punto di rottura
per farlo devi remare sulla tavola e vi
garantisco che prima o poi le braccia si
stancano
l'onda arriva e ti porta via con sé dove
vuole
oppure puoi provare a trasformare
quell'onda nella cosa più straordinaria
che esista sulla faccia della terra e
cavalcarla ora per riuscirci non bastano
fortuna o doti innate ma servono studio
ed esercizio studio per conoscere la
baia le sue correnti
i suoi 20 per conoscere il funzionamento
delle maree e saper scegliere la tavola
migliore da usare in quelle condizioni
ed esercizio perché è solo stando
immersi nell oceano che imparerete a
capire quale sarà il punto di rottura
dell'onda è il momento giusto per
alzarvi sulla tavola e quale sarà l'onda
migliore da provare a cavalcare e quando
parliamo di honda tecnologica le regole
sono le stesse
possiamo fuggire oppure cavalcare l'onda
e lo possiamo fare con studio ed
esercizio studio in questo caso
significa studio della società presente
dei suoi valori delle tecnologie e delle
loro potenzialità ed esercizio significa
immaginare e immergersi nel futuro per
imparare a capire quando arriverà l'onda
del cambiamento tecnologico
che tipo di impatti avrà e quale sia il
modo migliore per cavalcarla nella
giusta direzione
a proposito di direzione
vi ricordate quando per andare da
qualche parte usavamo le cartine
sembrano passati secoli eppure è stato
solo nel 2000 anche bill clinton ha
aperto all'uso civile
la tecnologia del gps trasformando le
cartine i navigatori satellitari e dopo
qualche anno in atto nel nostro
smartphone che non solo ci indicano la
strada ma ci consigliano anche quella
con meno traffico tra qualche anno tutto
questo sarà solo un ricordo
perché non saremo piu noi a interagire
con queste tecnologie che parleranno
direttamente con gli algoritmi alla
guida dei nostri veicoli a san francisco
in altre città auto così sono già per le
strade e la tesla model free che uscirà
nel 2018 non solo sarà elettrica è
dotata di software di guida autonoma ma
la potremo comprare per soli 35 mila
dollari si parla tantissimo di queste
auto e ha ragione
c'è chi dice che saranno 128 le cose che
scompariranno con questa innovazione non
avremo più bisogno di cartelli stradali
targhe guidatori io dico che i
cambiamenti saranno molti di più perché
tecnologie così impattano anche su
ambiti che non riguardano direttamente
ed è questo quello che io intendo con
honda tecnologica una tecnologia così
potente da essere in grado di cambiare
completamente tutte le regole del gioco
della società e della vita di tutti i
giorni
possiamo paragonarla a uno tsunami che
non ammette la possibilità di scappare o
di essere contenuto ma che con lo studio
e l'esercizio diventa cavalcabile e può
portarci verso lidi meravigliosi ed è
per questo che è così importante
studiare queste tecnologie che al giorno
d'oggi
arrivano una velocità tale per cui se
mancano lo studio e l'esercizio
diventano anche difficili da percepire
parliamo di intelligenza artificiale e
robotica stampa 3d
parliamo di genetica biotecnologie
nanotecnologie
parliamo di fonti di energia pulita
innovative e di block chain tecnologie
così potenti da essere in grado di
impattare su ogni aspetto della nostra
vita rivoluzionandolo e immergersi nel
futuro e studiarlo diventa un esercizio
non solo utile ma anche necessario per
capire il presente e decidere in quale
direzione andare
e più ci penso più nasce e cresce dentro
di me un senso di urgenza urgenza di
fare qualcosa di dirlo a tutti e di
conoscere l'opinione degli altri
ed è proprio dal confronto e grazie
all'aiuto di un gruppo di visionari che
la pensa come me che è nata in pack
school un'organizzazione che mette a
disposizione di tutti gratuitamente
formazione dibattito e collaborazione su
questi temi
solo nel 2017 abbiamo già lavorato con
oltre mille studenti in 14 università di
due diversi paesi europei ed entro fine
anno saranno almeno il triplo e saremo
già presenti in diversi continenti nel
prossimo step sono le scuole e tutti
quei luoghi dove ci sia qualcuno che
abbia voglia di prendere parte alla
discussione
portiamo per mano le persone nel futuro
lavorando con workshop che permettono di
immergersi in scenari probabili e di
discuterne le implicazioni e perché no
costruiamo anche insieme in scenari
migliori ad esempio lavoriamo in classe
con un caso come questo
robbie è un robot dotato di intelligenza
artificiale è molto carino ma è anche
straordinariamente avanzato
tanto che in grado di assistere in tutto
e per tutto
maria una signora anziana e non più
autosufficiente lo sapete che sono circa
un milione gli italiani che dedicano la
propria giornata a prendersi cura di un
parente robbie può portare un enorme
sollievo nella vita di queste persone e
in quello di maria restituendole
autonomia e dignità
si potrebbe obiettare che non sia giusto
togliere a maria il tocco umano di un
parente ma se robbie fosse anche un
ottima compagnia
se le permettesse di restare più attiva
e trascorrere il tempo in modo più
divertente
ad esempio sfidando la carte sì perché e
robbie ha impresso nel suo codice
l'obiettivo di massimizzare il benessere
di maria e per raggiungerlo farebbe
tutto il possibile e maria lo sa e pur
essendo un po sovrappeso riesce a
convincerlo che la cosa che la rende più
felice sia mangiare cioccolata fondente
e abbiamo pensarci io sono convinta che
mia nonna lo avrebbe convinto a
comprarli una stecca di sigarette al
giorno e e allora cosa dovrebbe fare
robbie in questa situazione e che
diritti avrebbe se maria dovesse
maltrattarlo per averle negato alla
cioccolata può sembrarvi qualcosa di
molto lontano ma a gennaio il parlamento
europeo ha sottolineato l'urgenza di
creare un quadro normativo che regoli le
responsabilità
e i diritti dei robot dando loro lo
status di electronic personal mood
in classe lavoriamo con questo e altri
temi che sono molto più attuali di
quanto pensiamo
il nostro compito è quello di accendere
la miccia far nascere il dibattito il
dubbio ma soprattutto è quello di fare
esercizio esercizio del nostro spirito
critico della nostra capacità di
collaborare esercizio di creatività e
immersione nel futuro queste capacità
sono state la chiave della nostra
evoluzione fin dai tempi dell'homo
sapiens sono alla base della nostra
umanità ed è arrivato il momento di
rimetterle al centro e allora perché non
esercitiamo quotidianamente a scuola al
lavoro in famiglia
non sono forse il libero arbitrio e la
capacità di immaginare il futuro
permettendoci di cacciare ad esempio
animali molto più grandi di noi che ci
hanno permesso di sopravvivere ed
evolverci nei millenni accendiamo la
miccia dicevo ea volte questa miccia si
trasforma in veri e propri incendi e
riusciamo a trasmettere quel famoso
senso di urgenza che all'origine della
nostra attività e allora succede
qualcosa di magico gruppi di persone che
partecipano appassionatamente al
dibattito lavorano insieme e scelgono di
far diventare la nostra missione anche
la loro organizzando a loro volta
workshop in tutto il mondo
stiamo creando una community che possa
non solo studiare ad esercitarsi ma
anche collaborare per costruire insieme
un futuro che tenga conto dei nostri
valori come esseri umani come società e
come individui
ed è proprio dai valori che dobbiamo
ripartire
un altro elemento fondamentale della
nostra umanità perché oggi quei valori
siamo chiamati a scriverli in un codice
che non è più quello delle leggi o delle
religioni
siamo chiamati a scriverli in software a
imprimerli nei prodotti e nei servizi
che usiamo tutti i giorni
dobbiamo imprimerli in robbie se
vogliamo che sia capace di stare al
nostro fianco e fornirgli gli strumenti
per decidere cosa fare con maria e la
cioccolata e che produce programma
queste tecnologie non può non tener
conto delle linee guida che nascono dal
lavoro che facciamo nei workshop robbie
le auto autonome e tutte le altre
tecnologie che arriveranno nel futuro
non sono altro che un estensione delle
nostre azioni potenziano le nostre
capacità
ed è per questo che siamo chiamati a
scegliere come vogliamo usarli sta solo
a noi decidere abbiamo un'enorme
responsabilità ma anche una
straordinaria opportunità per dimostrare
di essere umani lo spirito critico la
capacità di collaborare
la creatività sono la parte migliore
della nostra specie e insieme possiamo e
dobbiamo farne uso per diventare l'onda
inarrestabile verso il migliore dei
futuri possibili grazie